who says busy princess is don't really
exist we came across ten realized people
who look exactly like Disney royalty
right down to their big wide eyes their
facial expressions and their beautiful
hair these people have is convinced that
was just the right amount of effort
anyone can transform themselves into
their favorite princess if this is your
first time visiting our channel don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up because today
we're sharing ten people who shockingly
look like Disney Princesses Belle makeup
artist Richard Schafer from Orange
County California admits he's addicted
to Disney and he spends most of his free
time dressing up as some of his favorite
Disney Princesses in the photo richard
is dressed up as elves and the
resemblance between him and the princess
is shocking wearing a long brown wig and
a beautiful yellow gown to completed his
transformation with some flawless makeup
and very own prints no white Sara angel
from Denver Colorado has spent more than
14 thousand dollars on custom-made
costumes to transform herself into
various Disney Princesses here she is
it's a loveable Snow White it took her
about six months to have the dress
designed and created and after putting
on a short black wig some bright red
lipstick and dark eyeliner she looks
almost identical to Snow White all she's
missing is a Seven Dwarves and her print
of course Mulan
when Ariana Kwan was crowned to Miss
Michigan in 2016 everyone couldn't help
but notice her striking resemblance to
run the Chinese American Beauty Queen
can practically be Mulan twins they have
the same eyes the same round face and
identical smile if Ariana ever decides
to retire from the pageant world or
pretty sure she can make a living as a
Mulan impersonator baby Moana meet Elsa
Rose avidin she's an adorable little
girl who looks exactly like baby Moana
they have the same big beautiful brown
eyes the same adorable chubby cheeks and
even the same facial expression if the
movie Moana ever makes its way to
Broadway this baby should definitely be
a part of the cast
Rapunzel's twin sister did you
everything you'd see a real life upon go
neither did we until we came across this
photo of Los Angeles actress and model
Skylar valo
and we weren't the only ones to notice
the similarities between Skylar in the
Disney Princess she was actually hired
by Disneyland in Anaheim
California display Rapunzel at the
amusement park all it takes is 15 feet
of hair extensions and Rapunzel costumes
and Skyler is a dead ringer for the
Disney Princess they even have the same
wide smile a similar eye shape and the
exact same hair color real-life Arial
Malaysian makeup artist Saraswati have
some major skills when it comes to
transforming herself into real life
Disney Princesses each of our
transformations includes a hijab and
combined some impeccable makeup she
definitely looks like she and Ariel from
The Little Mermaid or separated at birth
she's even carrying around a fork just
like the princess the resemblance is
pretty shocking don't you agree the
Filipino Pocahontas Filipino model
sharyland sang of California and may not
be the same ethnicity as Pocahontas but
they have the exact same facial features
it's a mall of complexion the same eye
shape the exact same lips and the same
beautiful hair Sherri works as a
registered nurse and we're pretty sure
she gets soft in the hospital's hallways
all day long with people mistaking her
for the Disney Princess we're definitely
convinced these feet are long-lost
sisters the Elsa look-alike one of the
most popular Disney Princesses Elsa from
frozen has a real-life twin sister Lydia
luangta nub Reading Berkshire discovers
she resembled the ice princess after
dressing up in announce a costume to
entertain children at a local mall the
registered nurse posed for pictures and
eventually parents began hiring her to
come to their children's birthday
parties Lydia takes her resemblance to
also very seriously she has watched
frozen over 30 times so that she can
really bring the Disney princess to life
the American Merida an anonymous reddit
user designed a medieval dress grabbed
her bow and arrow and asked fellow rent
users if she resembled braids Merida
when her image ended up on the homepage
of the website the answer was clear
she's definitely married as identical
twins the natural redhead has the same
wild and untamed hair as the Disney
Princess and the same Doughty lift and
she even has a love for archery just
like the princess 20 with Jasmine Olay
in jamia Noel of New York dressed up as
a princess jasmine for Halloween and her
photo was so shocking that the image
went viral people all over the world
began telling her just how similar she
looks to be a Latin character
she says jasmine was always her favorite
Disney Princess and after purchasing for
$10 costumes she realized
she's definitely 20 with the busy
princess can you place them side-by-side
it's definitely hard to tell isn't ooh
what can these real-life Disney
Princesses is your favorite react in the
comment section below and don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up
you